how's it going red is my name is Paris
and it's no ears you know what that
means
but it has nothing to do with time
travel you're you're drunk already
yeah okay I'll I'll keep this brief I
just want to say thank you Bruce
for this amazing year I had so much fun
making all these videos it's been quite
a journey so far I mean we had 19
million subscribers as always this is
stupid
but hey I'm going with it it's been an
amazing year and it's really all thanks
to you bros like all the success and
everything I have with this channel it's
all thanks to you bros and I have not
forgotten that so I just wanted to say
thank you without you bro support and
just watching my videos every day and
liking or commenting and all that
whatever you choose to participate I
really appreciate that's what makes
YouTube fun for me without you brother
there's no way I would we keep making
these videos so it really means the
world to me that you bros are always so
supportive so yeah 2014 I can't wait to
make even more videos for you brother
it's gonna be even better I know this
because I have a time-travel thing my
new year's resolution probably this is
make sense to what I just said would
probably relax more I really work a lot
on these videos every single day night
sometimes I don't even sleep but I do it
because I love it but I hope I can find
better balance in what I do and enjoy
cuz there are things in life that I want
to enjoy what are you Bruce New Year's
resolution let me know in the comments a
lot of hugs a lot of kisses you bros are
the best yeah shove this message down
you throw it already but really Rose
Rock my [ __ ]
can can can can canoe here's for a new
awesome year can't wait to share it with
you breath as always you know it already
cut stay awesome breath love you
[Music]